this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
and today he's going to be taking a look
at the weaponry of 2013's
battlefield 4. this i think is the most
interesting weapon that we've seen
from battlefield 4 in that it is in fact
made up if you want to see more of
jonathan reacting to battlefield guns
make sure to subscribe and check out our
videos on battlefield 1
and battlefield 5. but you know watch
this video first
if there are any other games guns and
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down let us know in the
comment section below
and if you'd like to help out the royal
army's museum and continue to support
jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right
over to jonathan
right we've got the f-2000 the fn
f-2000 and it's a really quite
interesting
design uh i have one here here it is um
i've seen it described as the tactical
tuner chasing tuna fish because it is
an odd shape or you might say an odd
fish
in british english so pretty much as it
appears in the game
something i noticed pretty much right
away was how
the upper receiver
seems to be quite shiny almost looks
like it's metal
in the game in real life at least it is
all
glass reinforced polymer which makes it
really quite lightweight for for what it
is it's got quite a long
20 inch barrel in a in a short package
which of course is the whole bullpup
idea i did have to check but the
magazine
the the reload animation in the game is
correct you
press in and pull out and then all you
have to do is
insert the magazine we see that the
character give it a
slap as well which depending which armed
force you may or may not have been part
of may or may not have
gotten you a slap
we've got a sniper rifle here this is
the the desert tech
uh srs or stealth recon scout
game name is generic of course 338
scout uh it does come in 338 lapwer
magnum
among other calibers and it is a bolt
action
bullpup sniper rifle depicted pretty
faithfully
in bf4 this is more of a general issue
with the battlefield games
and it may just be my perception but um
all the ones i've
ever played seem to have really
pronounced bullet drop
although they're quite you know very
large open maps i think
something super powerful like a 338
lapper
has a relatively flat trajectory out to
some distance whereas
we seem to get a fair bit of drop
okay we've got here uh a rarity
in the real world not so much in games i
did look up the list and there's
at least a dozen different games that
have featured this this is the mp412
rex this is an interesting design
especially from a
historical standpoint because from the
1870s
there were a number of designs famously
the smith and wesson
number three that broke open so you
press a catch
all of those had including the wrecks
had automatic ejection
so the ejector star-shaped ejector
pushes up on the rims of the cases
and they go flying out and it's quite
it's quite fun in the game i've never
seen it done
with the real one because i've never
seen a real one but um in the game the
way they sort of all
flower out with with a flourish is quite
pleasing to watch
and that's well it's interesting because
part of the reason we moved away from
that was the strength of the frame
for for increasingly more powerful
revolver cartridges a solid frame with a
swing out cylinder
was better with modern materials you can
in fact design a break open revolver
that is strong enough to handle in this
case
357 magnum revolver cartridges so it's
it's uh
a real sort of sci-fi looking design but
was never produced
none exists in the uk i don't think any
made it to the states
uh maybe there's a sample here or there
but i've never seen one if so
is it me or is the player character
bringing cartridges to the loading ports
which magically open on their own is it
me or is that what's happening
i don't think it's me i think they're
opening on their own there are
various things wrong with that by the
way this is the uts 15
which is a real thing as i'm sure people
who played the game
already know it does work pretty much as
depicted
so seven seven rounds in each side in
tubes
and that's what we see getting loaded um
it's a bit confusing as to what's
actually going on in the real
gun you have to stoke up the two pipes
with seven rounds
and then you put the last one onto the
the
conveyor and then you close the pump
grip and
load the final shot now that's a safety
thing more than anything
so what we may be seeing here that i'm
just not quite catching is that
the first round the 15th round gets
loaded first
so it's it's um it's depicted pretty
well but um the
the reload is slightly irksome
this is what i remember using in
battlefield 4
myself uh out of curiosity as well as
out of
interest to see if it was effective in
the game or not um the xm25 which
received the
um slightly macho name of punisher so
this this was a spin-off of the old
objective infantry combat weapon of late
90s early 2000s
somewhat as we see in the clip there the
25 millimeter grenades are not
big enough in terms of explosive payload
to have the same sort of effect as say
a 40 millimeter grenade so you've got
this big heavy weapon that can't fire
bullets
can only fire 25 millimeter grenades but
they don't really have the explosive
power
but the really interesting thing about
it is something that was implemented in
the game which is the
fusing the sensor fusing system which is
the big bulky sight thing on the top
and in the game you aim the distance you
want to hit
beyond which you want to hit and then
you aim up and shoot
and the grenade air bursts i think three
in-game meters beyond that
which from the promotional material put
out by by the makers of this
does seem to be somewhat how it would
have actually worked in real life
dice did a good job of representing this
very interesting capability
of putting explosives putting giant
explody bullets
where you need them to go but are they
powerful enough
so an an interesting moment in times of
2013 when
this thing was actually a viable
prospect and it's not anymore
i think we've spoken before on this
series about the master key
under barrel shotgun well as a secondary
weapon to your
to the rifle that it's attached to and
as a way to be able to take down door
hinges
as a breaching weapon there was clearly
enough of a niche use for that
that the us government decided that they
wanted a
dedicated short shotgun that could be
attached to an assault rifle for
infantry use
and that's what the m26 is and it's
as you can see very compact manually
operated so you
as we see there pump action but with it
with a great big bolt handle
and that's whether it's attached to a
rifle or as we've seen the clip
attached to its own stand-alone stock to
be used
as well a standalone weapon we saw some
quite impressive long-range kills
there which i'm just sort of pleased by
in the
shotguns do not create huge spread that
we see in games we've talked about that
on here before
but i'm almost surprised that given how
short that barrel is that we are getting
such lethality
at distance with guys presumably wearing
body armor
that that's quite an effective weapon
but of course that's balanced by being
quite slow
i can't help feeling this is a bit of
copycat from
modern warfare with its uh 1887
lever action shotgun that seemed
completely incongruous with the setting
because this is it's called the mayor's
leg the mayor's leg
was invented for a 1950s tv series with
um steve mcqueen in it i think that was
a
winchester 1892 cut down and then it
kind of
became a sort of meme in a way um and
was in lots of other
series and movies so it's a pistol
it's a a a lever action rifle cut down
to act as a pistol hence it's in the
handgun category in the game
hence it's in 44 magnum which is a
pistol caliber
this is i think based on a marlin lever
action design and a modernized one with
picatinny rails all over it
and a really weird looking lever loop
which i don't think is based on anything
from the real world
um and it as far as i can tell it's
really not very good either
so best of luck to those of you still
using that one
oh that's a that's a good clip because
we've got as well as the dreaded mare's
leg we've also got
two weapons to talk about both of which
have an israeli
origin the tavor x95 or micro
tavor mtar mtar21 and to jump to the
other weapon
the shoulder mounted rocket launcher
that was
originally the b300 which was developed
by
iwy when they were imi israeli military
industries
and the reason it looks so short is uh
we've probably gathered from the reload
animation
that the back end is actually the rocket
munition in a housing
now interestingly that's being fired
from a parachute now recoil wise that
would be doable
but you're aiming the back end up into
your chute which
which is at the very least is going to
disturb the direction that you're
parachuting in
and might actually shred your lines
tangle your lines put a hole in the
canopy i don't know i'm not a
parachutist
i wouldn't want to try it i don't think
it's any in anyone's manuals
so back to the to the tavor so this is a
bit of a snapshot in time because this
early version of the x95
wasn't really in use for very long uh
before it got upgraded to the new
version
and everyone else is using the standard
tavor so um battlefield
captures that and then projects it
forward to 2020 by which
time there are i mean aren't going to be
many people using this specific variant
this is the sort of weapon you would
want if if you require
to be able to shoot bullets out to sort
of 300 meters but your main job is to
carry a big well what we call light
weapons but they're not that light
like the small so your pro your primary
role is
putting large munitions on target but
you need something to be able to either
either defend yourself
or in a pinch to fight like infantry
with if required
something compact like this is ideal
all right we'll pause um being a game
whose conceit is the us versus china
obviously we need some chinese weapons
in the game so this is
obviously what this is the qbb 95 or
type 95
light machine gun unfortunately we don't
have
any of the modern generation chinese
weapons
in the royal armouries collection which
means i don't have any experience to to
offer to make any
real insights but um it's it's
from the available material it's a
pretty close
approximation the only thing that's
that's definitely wrong
is that it's got a picatinny rail on the
carrying handle
which i'm as sure as i can be has not
been done
not to the that generation of chinese
weapons anyway i believe with their
latest generation as most countries in
the world are they are looking at
integrating that standard because it's
become
from being an american standard it's
become a nato standard so it has to be
in the game really for what it is
and is it an accurate representation uh
ask someone from china
[Applause]
this i think is the most interesting
weapon that we've seen
from battlefield 4 in that it is in fact
made up as as they've done here with a
bit of crystal ball gazing from 2013
2012 2013
to 2020 when the game is set there's no
real reason to assume that
the russians would adopt an ak-12 based
dmr which is what this is
so a bit a bit of um near future
speculation that didn't really go as
planned because
the russian forces are still using the
svd svds
and svdm alongside increasing numbers of
the ak-12 but it's not the ak-12
that this is based on that was done away
with and that's not the developer's
fault
the real world changes after you make a
decision and there's nothing you can do
about that
if you check the description you'll find
links to
two different ways in which you can
support the royal armouries
and everything that we do including the
work that we do here with gamespot
hope to see you again next time
[Music]
[Music]
you